>> ON THIS VOTE FOR YOU AS ARE
228.
THE AS ARE 197.
THE BILL IS PASSED.
CARLEY: THE HOUSE HAS PAST TWO
IMMIGRATION REFORM BILLS MAKING
IT EASIER FOR DREAMERS AND
MIGRANT FARMWORKERS TO BECOME
CITIZENS BUT IS THIS FAIR TO THE
IMMIGRANTS WHO CAME HERE
LEGALLY.
HERE TO WEIGH IN A LEGAL
IMMIGRANT FROM HUNGARY WHO
FOUNDED THE ANGEL FAMILIES OF
AMERICA.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS BECAUSE YOU
CAME HERE LEGALLY AND AS YOU SAW
THE HOUSE JUST PAST TWO BILLS
THAT WOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR
FOLKS WHO DIDN’T COME HERE
LEGALLY, DREAMERS AND MIGRANT
FARMWORKERS TO GET THAT
CITIZENSHIP.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THESE
TWO BILLS?
>> THIS IS INCREDIBLY
DISAPPOINTING.
WE ARE EXPERIENCING THE MOST
CORRUPT DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS IN
THE HISTORY OF THE UNITED
STATES.
WE PASSED THE AMNESTY BILL BY
THAT AND PROVE TO BE A TOTAL
FAILURE.
THIS IS A SLAP IN THE FACE OF
EVERY LEGAL IMMIGRANT WHO
FOLLOWED THE LAW AND A SLAP IN
THE FACE TO THE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED AND
IN A TIME OF CRISIS IN A
PANDEMIC WE ARE BRINGING MORE
ILLEGAL ALIENS, FAMILIES AND
ANTS AND COUSINS AND THIS IS NOT
FAIR.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
DISAPPOINTING.
JILLIAN: MIKE DIAZ, LEGAL
IMMIGRANT FROM MEXICO AS WELL,
YOU HAVE ARRIVED AS WELL,
LEGALLY IMMIGRATED FROM
NICARAGUA.
I WANT YOUR TAKE ON THIS BECAUSE
EVERYBODY SEES THE FOOTAGE OF
PEOPLE COMING TO THIS COUNTRY
AND THEIR HEARTS GO OUT TO THEM
BECAUSE THEY ARE IN A DESPERATE
STATE AND WANTS TO GET HERE SO
BADLY BUT YOU IMMIGRATED HERE
FROM MEXICO LEGALLY SO WHAT IS
YOUR TAKE ON THIS?
>> ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, THE FOLKS
WANT TO BE IN AMERICA AND SEE
THIS AS A LAND OF OPPORTUNITY
AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE HAVE BUT
THERE IS A PROCESS AND IT IS,
LIKE THE OTHER SPEAKER WAS
SAYING FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
DONE IT LEGALLY IT IS A SLAP IN
THE FACE AND FOR THOSE THAT ARE
GOING THROUGH PROCESS, THEY ARE
FRUSTRATED HOW THEY HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING RIGHT ONLY TO HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION OPENED THE BORDER
AND ALLOW FOLKS TO COME IN BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY THE
PROBLEM IS BIGGER THAN A
FAIRNESS ISSUE AND WHEN I THINK
ABOUT WHAT OTHER FOLKS, IT
AFFECTS MANY AMERICANS THAT MAY
BE AMERICAN BORN, THE LABOR POOL
FOR EXAMPLE IS AFFECTED BY THE
SURGE OF IMMIGRANTS.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, WHERE I LIVE
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY IS A HUB FOR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SO YOU GOT TO
LOOK AT THE HUMAN SUFFRAGE GOING
ON CREATED BY THESE POLICIES.
THAT IS WHAT YOU KEEP PEOPLE
THAT MIGHT NOT WHETHER IT IS
FAIR FOR ME AS AN IMMIGRANT WHO
CAME LEGALLY, BUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO THOSE KIDS AND
ADULTS AS THEY ARE CAPTURED IN
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
>> THERE IS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
FOR DREAMERS BUT CONGRESSMAN
STEVE SCALISE SAYS AS WE FACE
THE BORDER CRISIS IT SENDS THE
WRONG SIGNAL BECAUSE MORE PEOPLE
WILL WANT TO COME OVER AND THESE
TWO BILLS, THEY WILL HAVE A MORE
DIFFICULT TIME IN THE SENATE.
SENATOR DICK DURBIN DID TALK
ABOUT THESE BILLS, LEGISLATIVE
SOLUTION IS OVERDUE FOR DREAMERS
WHO DEVOTED THEIR LIVES TO OUR
COUNTRY, UNDOCUMENTED MIGRANTS,
FARMWORKERS DOING BACKBREAKING
AGRICULTURE WORK TO KEEP FOOD ON
OUR TABLE, AND TPS RECIPIENTS
WHO BUILD THEIR LIVES HERE AND
MAKING ESSENTIAL CONTRIBUTIONS
TO OUR NATIONAL RECOVERY, CAN
YOU RESPOND TO THAT?
>> I WOULD LIKE SAY NEVERTHELESS
IT IS INSULTING TO THE PEOPLE
WHO WAITED YEARS TO COME AND
HAVE GONE THROUGH THIS PROCESS
OF STUDYING THE CONSTITUTION,
THE BILL OF RIGHTS, THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE, SO
THEY CAN BECOME CITIZENS AND BE
ABLE TO VOTE.
IT IS NOT TREATED WITH THE
PRIVILEGE.
WITH THIS BILL THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO VOTE ALMOST RIGHT AWAY OR
VOTE LEGALLY ABOUT BE
PERSECUTED.
I SAID PROSECUTED.
A TREMENDOUS SLAP IN THE FACE
FOR ANGEL MOMS THAT HAVE LOST
CHILDREN.
>> AGNES IS ONE OF THEM.
WE RAN OUT OF TIME AND YOUR
PERSPECTIVE, OLIVER YOUR
OPINIONS ARE IMPORTANT BECAUSE